a big topic for us in 2019 so far has
been the growing threat from the
anti-vaccine community not just in the
United States but in a lot of different
parts of the world mentioned early on in
the year that anti-vaccine sentiment has
been listed by the World Health
Organization as one of the top 10 global
health threats of the year
Canada is getting really serious about
this issue and I absolutely love it
they've sent out 6,000 suspension
notices to parents of children in the
Waterloo Region which is in the province
of Ontario and the notices say that the
school department doesn't have proof of
vaccinations or valid exemption requests
for these roughly 6100 kids now this is
not all anti vaccine sentiment and I'll
explain what's going on with a lot of
these kids it's just a matter of getting
the vaccination records to the public
health officials with some of these kids
they are not vaccinated and the parents
are going to have to make a decision
about whether they're going to have
their kids vaccinated by March 26th
whether they are going to pull them out
of public school and send them to
private school if that's something that
they can afford and are interested in
doing if they're going to request a an
exemption from vaccinations or if the
kids are going to end up suspended
potentially for 20 days from school and
there's a really interesting dynamic
here because a lot of people emailed me
and then they said hope David I'm
reading this story but schools have
required vaccination records in Canada
for a really long time why is this
happening all of a sudden and it's
really interesting a lot of the school
districts that require vaccination
records didn't really pursue the records
because everybody was vaccinated or
almost everybody was vaccinated there
was no problem with the anti-vaccine
movement the anti-vaccine movement is
now growing so nothing has changed in
terms of requiring vaccination records
what's changed is that now the schools
are getting stricter about actually
requesting those records and what what's
also important just to remind everybody
about here is that vaccinations are
not mandatory in the sense that the
government is forcing people to
vaccinate themselves or their children
Canada isn't forcing anybody to get a
vaccine Canada or better said Waterloo
Ontario is saying if you want your kids
to go to public school you either need
to give us a vaccination record or a
valid waiver from vaccinations it's all
up to the parents the parents can say
I'm in a home school the parents can say
I'm going to send them to a private
school the parents can say I'm going to
try to get an exemption from
vaccinations and parents who have
vaccinated their kids should be really
glad that this is being done because you
want a system that's going to shake out
the anti-vaxxers who might be
endangering their kids of course no
vaccine is 100% effective herd immunity
is the name of the game you have kids
who are immunocompromised who can't be
vaccinated you have kids who are doing
the right thing and getting vaccinated
their parents are doing the right thing
but because the vaccines not a hundred
percent everybody who opts merely not to
vaccinate because they don't want to is
putting everybody at risk and what you
really need to understand here is that
there are centuries of medical progress
with vaccines as one of the greatest
contributors to that progress that
progress is being threatened by people
who just don't want to vaccinate their
kids religious exemptions should not be
allowed period send your kid to a
private school homeschool them don't use
religion as a tool to endanger a
publicly funded government-run school
system it just can't be allowed to
happen and meanwhile it's not just in
Canada that this is a problem the
anti-vaccine movement is exploding I
have so many stories I've been hoping to
get to about this we learned about a
father whose family is the epicenter of
the vancouver canada measles outbreak
his name is emmanuel Bilodeau he says
the reason he didn't vaccinate his kids
is he was afraid that the measles
vaccine the MMR vaccine would give them
autism Japan is having a measles
outbreak there's a religious group
called Q sankyo which operates in the me
a
Prefecture that's the center of a
measles outbreak they are now
apologizing for the outbreak they are
known to spread anti vaccine nonsense
they're saying they're not going to do
it anymore
and then by the way Madagascar is now
dealing with almost 70,000 reported
cases of measles and the connection to
the anti vaccine sentiment in Madagascar
is still being explored we don't know to
what extent that's connected so it's
getting really bad parts of the United
States Washington State and Oregon are
epicenters in the US Canada Australia
we've talked about a number of countries
in Europe including Italy and one other
that I'm forgetting Japan now dealing
with this and Madagascar now dealing
with this and there are people who sort
of laugh at this and say David it's
Darwinian selection anybody who doesn't
get vaccinated is going to be less
likely to live long enough to pass on
their genes to children and you'll just
sort of have anti-vaxxers die off not
true because unfortunately much of the
risk around not vaccinating people is
around people who can't get vaccines the
vaccines are not a hundred percent
effective so it's not just Darwinian
selection that we can all laugh at this
is a serious health issue and that's why
the w-h-o has designated it as such for
2019